-Chevrolet is committed
to an electric future
by making electric vehicles
more accessible for everyone.
-Wow, everyone?
-Oh, I'm sorry.
This is one of my writers,
John Lutz.
Uh, John,
what are you doing here?
-Well, I wanted to thank you.
-Thank me for what?
-For getting everyone who works
here at "Late Night"
a Chevy electric vehicle
for our holiday bonus.
-Lutz, I'm not giving everyone
an electric vehicle.
-Okay.
Then, uh...
Then, just me?
-No.
-Aw, come on.
I've worked here
since the show started.
What has that been,
like three years?
-It's been almost nine.
-Yeah. Yeah, it's been nine.
But when you count
how much I actually worked,
it's only been two.
[ Chuckles ]
-I'm not getting you an E.V.
-Fine.
How about a scooter?
-No.
-A bike?
-Skateboard?
-You know, I gotta be honest.
I'm just having trouble
seeing you on a skateboard.
-What? Why?
Because of all this?
-Whoo-whoo!
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They can see it.
They can see it.
Come on, Seth,
you gotta give me something.
This is the holidays.
-Uh, alright.
Eh, fine.
Come on over here.
Um...
What if I gave you, um...
that.
-Aha! Sold!
[ Laughs ] Whoo! Score!
-Hey, Seth,
I'd also like to thank you
for my holiday bonus --
an all-electric
Chevy Equinox E.V.
-Wait, what?
-You're welcome, Wally.
You deserve it, pal.
-Thanks, Seth.
Hey, nice mug, Lutz.
-Yeah, I got a mug.
Hooray for me.
[ Laughs tightly ]
[ Inhales sharply ]
Have an electric holiday,
everybody!
-Yikes!
At least you didn't end this one
with that stupid wink.
-[ Laughing ]
Oh, I almost forgot!
Thanks for reminding me, Seth.
Have an electric holiday.
Wink!
-Wink!